just the only way is if somehow they get  a five-second violation  yeah but if i'm kyle lowry i'll just  throw it in absolutely  ciaco goes into backcourt looking throws  it up and that'll do it  brad stevens was upset it's all over the  raptors win  and their season is still alive there  will be a game seven  fittingly in this series some amazing  individual performances  marcus smart upset they thought they  were the  the celtics were trying to draw a foul  and you see the players jawing at each  other  you don't want to see a great  competitive game spoiled by anything  afterwards the  celtic players trying to get smart away  from the raptor players  this was just great theater here in the  bubble  two teams giving everything they got  in an important playoff game nick  nursing get to the locker room get off